hey there this is exciting I'm in
Jamaica Plain Boston and I'm at the site
of the Samuel Adams brewery why am I
here well Sam Adams sponsored my tour no
money changed hands today okay and here
is a fan we got the check last week
these people think this is a hotel and
they're checking in it's not a hotel
it's a brewery I don't know why you have
luggage you're insane you're going to a
brewery it's not a hotel this is Jim
cook Jim good to meet you welcome to our
brewery thank you is the founder and
brewer here at Sam Adams you've been at
this for quite a while
34 years 34 years longer than you've
been drinking no no I started drinking
when I was 1 years old so listen what's
going on you walk into the brewery and
what's sitting here but to Sam Adams
well of course
did you have to go to the Samuel Adams
family to license the name no really
yeah let guys sign the Declaration of
Independence if you're a public figure
when you die your name enters the public
domain but for example I could I don't
know I could start selling the abraham
lincoln vape pen it's great that you
have all of this excuse me hold on a sec
taught me off going faster than you
you taught me off there pal you've got a
little problem here on the floor hold on
oh I get it
we're going to the brewery yeah fear has
been around for ten thousand years human
beings went from like wandering around
gathering roots and berries killing
small animals to settling down in
villages they settled down to make fear
they grew grain and the best way to get
the nutritional value and the grade so
like 12,000 years ago in Mesopotamia
people started growing grain to light
the public and after four or five days
they'd stop and they could drink it
there's nothing in the conflict that
human beings can grow into be twins
the Mayflower game Windham Jim I'm gonna
stop you for a second
you've got to tighten it up a little bit
thousand years in yeah your second day
by day yeah
all right where are we now that's worthy
of Co guram they came over here they put
no water on the Mayflower only beers
right and now into the nation pinky toes
and daiquiris and Chardonnay they
founded a nation on beer Jim you're
getting belligerent I got it let me tell
you what's going on here
I really doubt if you've something
what's going on here I think I take my
own life this is about families where
I'm a Brewers 25 years have you ever
listened to Jim tell you about the
history of beer I've known Jim for 25
years I've heard it more than once
absolutely really so you've heard it
twice
one story I'm interested in learning
what beers made of hops act as a
preservative the hops are the closest
botanical relative to marijuana but to
get the gland you really want the glands
that's it
and now sniffing I'm just like Charlie
the Chocolate Factory I'm gonna be
honest with you now and tell you I stole
these hops and I'm gonna put them back
right now and that means you're gonna be
impressed with my honesty and you're
gonna give me the brewery maybe we'll
give you some beer but not the whole
thing man Willy Wonka gave the whole
thing away he was an idiot in the new
brewery was where we make all of our new
beers new styles that come out of Boston
beer cool yeah I'm sorry I'm transfixed
by your beard what are you for the
beards
what is it the beards here yeah everyone
had no control over facial hair
[Laughter]
this version of Santa's workshop it just
looks like the police are coming they
have a picture of you and you quickly
clip this thing around this is
incredible and look at yours can you
touch his to his how many types of beer
do we have here 28 28 it is my duty as
your representative to try every one of
these beers
alright let's move on to the next one so
this is the noble I'm pretty attractive
I don't know why I said that okay so
what does that - what do we have 26 26
to go all right that's gonna take too
long we do not mind gentlemen I have a
solution I'm gonna make a little blend
here gentlemen is a beer what the
chances are this is pretty good I know
yeah what do you think it's a mess
the common man wants twenty six beers
mixed together
you guys are overthinking it this is
amazing this is what Samuel Adams was
all about this is my declaration of
independence what do you get when you
combine dozens of beers with one drunk a
revolution the Conan brew a simple blend
of 26 randomly selected beers 28 beers
plus two disoriented tours
the comon boo from Sam Adams and Jim
cook and I do not approve this beer